we're learning new details about the
mid-air engine explosion that killed one
passenger on a Southwest Airlines jet
Jennifer Reardon a married mother of two
died yesterday when engine parts
shattered a window on flight 1380
from New York to Dallas passengers are
calling the female pilot a hero or
calmly guiding the plane to safety
captain Tammy Joe Schultz is a former
fighter jet pilot Kris Van Cleave is at
Philadelphia International Airport new
details on the investigation Kris good
morning good morning pieces of the
engine cover were found on the ground 75
miles from here and now the National
Transportation Safety Board says they
found signs of metal fatigue in an
engine fan blade that broke off that may
be the cause of this horrible accident
Southwest says that engine as cfm56 was
nearly 20 years old but had been
serviced just three days ago
roughly 20 minutes after takeoff at
about 32,000 feet Southwest flight 1380s
left engine exploded the blast sent
shrapnel tearing through one of the
plane's windows causing the cabin to
lose pressure terrified passengers like
Marty Martinez reached for oxygen masks
as the plane rapidly descended Jennifer
Reardon was killed after she was
partially sucked out of the shattered
window other passengers pulled her back
in and tried unsuccessfully to perform
CPR NTSB chairman Robert Sun Walt the
fan section that we're talking about
today is designed such that if a part
does come off it would not be
catastrophic for the airplane had this
window not been punctured today's event
would have just been another emergency
landing passengers called captain Tammy
Joe Schultz a hero for safely landing
the damaged plane according to friends
at her alma mater Schultz was among the
first female fighter pilots in the US
Navy Tuesday's engine failure is not the
first for Southwest linked to metal
fatigue in August 2016 a similar event
occurred
on a flight to Orlando that 737 landed
safely with no one hurt
but metal from the engine sliced into
the fuselage we are very concerned about
it there needs to be proper inspection
mechanisms in place to check for this
before there's a catastrophic event and
after that 2016 failure the FAA has been
moving to require enhanced inspections
of some older cfm56 engines similar to
this one Southwest says it's going to
accelerate its existing engine
inspection program Riordan is the first
passenger onboard a u.s. airliner to be
killed in more than nine years John
harrowing and tragic thank you Chris